hey guys my name is Jess today is the
11th of July and you're watching games
for new GF coming no man's sky
apparently has 18 quintillion planets
for you to explore but it seems all
those planets are only going to take up
6 gigabytes of space on a ps4 blu-ray
founder of hello games and creator of no
man's sky Sean Murray revealed the
figure on Twitter where he added that a
lot of that space is actually taken up
by audio this is likely due to the fact
that the planets are procedurally
generated so they don't need so much
room to actually be stored on the disk
mari also revealed that no man's sky has
passed certification in Europe the US
and asia and the studio was already hard
at work on update 1 no man's sky went
gold on july seven and is due out on
august nine in north america next up the
compilation of remastered batman games
Batman returned to Arkham may have been
delayed until at least November Batman
returned to Arkham is slated doing food
remastered versions of Batman Arkham
Asylum and Arkham City for ps4 and Xbox
one the game was supposed to launch on
July 26 but at the end of June warner
brothers announced that the game was
delayed indefinitely now multiple
sources have told Eurogamer that Batman
returned to Arkham will arrive in
November at the earliest sources
suggests that the developer virtuous
games is struggling with framerate
issues this is in line with what Warner
Brothers said last month when they
explained after reviewing the progress
of the project the team at WB games has
decided to delay the release of Batman
returned to Arkham to give the team at
virtuous games additional time to
deliver a polished batman arkham game
experience finally people are still
super keen on Pokemon go at least when
the servers are working and it now seems
that catching pokemon is more popular
than going on dates or telling people on
the internet that you bought a diet coke
according to data from similar web the
Pokemon Go app is now more popular than
tinder on Android phones and it's set to
surpass Twitter as well the app is
currently installed on five point one
six percent of phones which might not
seem like all that many but given
there's over a billion Android phones
out there that's not bad on top of that
more than sixty percent of people with
the app
it every day Pokemon go users also use
the app for an average of 43 minutes
each day which is higher than what's up
Instagram snapchat and Facebook
Messenger although Pokemon go isn't
actually made by nintendo it has helped
nintendo shares I rocket ten percent
last week and twenty five percent in
just the last day their highest jump
since 1983 developer niantic labs said
they will be introducing a trading
feature in a future update and they also
intend to make improvements to poker
stops and gyms which the dev of said are
now only their very most basic versions
a global leader board system is also on
its way as our improvements to the games
or granted reality systems so Pokemon
will look better and blended into the
real world let me know in the comment
box what you want to see the app try out
next you shot ahead to game slots where
we've got stories on Rainbow six siege
and a battlefield TV show I'll be back
tomorrow with a bunch more news